TERRY RYAN: Today, we're
talking about GitOps
for GKE, Anthos Ready
Storage, and a new cloud
region for Korea.
I'm Terry Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Application Manager
is a beta add-on
to Google Kubernetes
Engine that leverages
GitOps principles to help you
manage release configurations.
This cluster add-on pulls
Kubernetes manifests
from a Git repository
and then deploys those
as an application
in the cluster.
Give it a try and let
us know what you think.
The Stackdriver cloud
monitoring dashboards
API is now generally available.
This API lets you read
configurations, create, update,
and delete dashboards
programmatically.
Now you can easily
duplicate dashboards
across dev and 2a environments,
or make templates out
of your favorites.
Anthos Ready Storage
is a new qualification
for partner storage
solutions that
have met core requirements
for storage recommendations
and optimal on-prem performance.
These include dynamic
provisioning with Kubernetes
native storage APIs,
Automatic Storage Management
across scale up and
scale down scenarios,
and a simplified
deployment experience.
Check it out to see if these
solutions can work for you.
Our new GCP region in Seoul is
officially open for business.
Designed to support
Korean customers,
the new Seoul region is
comprised of three zones,
enabling customers and partners
to run high availability
workloads and store
their data locally.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.